très après le fiasco des masques et des
tests l'exécutif espère bien on l'aura
compris malgré un le retard réussir sa
campagne de vaccination une sortie de
crise qui lui permettrait d'aborder plus
sereinement la présidentielle en 2022
arnaud montbourg à ce propos discret
depuis un moment déjà s'est d'ailleurs
exprimé sur ce sujet de manière assez
surprenante
dans une interview accordée au quotidien
britannique financial times consacré un
éventuel duel marine le pen emmanuel
macron et bien l'ancien ministre du
redressement productif qui va de son
pronostic pour lui et bien c'est marine
le pen qui va l'emporter car
explique-t-il
le chef de l'état n'est pas un rempart
contre le rassemblement national
il compare cette victoire anticipé au
phénomène trump ou break site
alors comme le prédit arnaud montebourg
marine le pen va t'elle gagner
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22
places à notre décryptage avec nos
invités avec nous pour en parler arnaud
benedetti rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire vous êtes un
spécialiste de la communication
politique denis jacquet entrepreneurs
auteur également vous publié à la fin du
mois le début de la peur la faim d'une
démocratie aux éditions eyrolles et puis
alexis poulain qu'on connaît bien sur
notre antenne éditorialiste sur rt
france bonsoir messieurs merci à tous
les trois d'être en direct sur rt france
donc un an et un mois précisément de
l'élection présidentielle certains
candidats potentiels ne mâchent pas
leurs mots un parmi eux l'ancien
ministre socialiste de l'économie arnaud
montebourg gardien ce qu'il dit du chef
de l'état dans les colonnes du financial
times macron et détester parce qu'il est
arrogant
ce n'est pas un rempart c'est lui qui
mettra madame le pen au pouvoir
il vise juste arnaud montebourg alexis
poule 1 les mots sont durs
les mots sont durs mais mesurée
néanmoins on a vu effectivement que ce
fameux remparts promis par emmanuel
macron contre emma contre marine le pen
a été une autoroute une course à
l'échalote face aux idées de madame le
pen et du rassemblement national
d'ailleurs elles votent souvent en
accord avec les lois proposées par la
majorité présidentielle en disant
qu'elle n'aurait pas fait mieux
et rappelez-vous le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin face à elle
sur un plateau de télévision qui la
trouvaient trop molle donc c'est vous
dire que oui emmanuel macron est loin
d'être un rempart face à marine le pen
dont les idées sont devenus quasiment
majoritaire au sein de la société
française si on en croit les médias qui
jour après jour vont resservir à peu
près les mêmes débats sur l'islamophobie
sur le voile sur le séparatisme sur
plein d'autres choses mais quand on
creuse un peu madame le pen est tout à
fait raccord également avec emmanuel
macron sur la politique européenne
elle est devenue finalement pro europe
elle est devenue également chantre de la
dette en disant qu'il faudra de toute
façon rembourse la dette
et puis elle est en train de revenir et
à droite après avoir essayé de draguer
les classes populaires en disant qu'elle
était anti système
elle est tout à fait partie prenante du
système certains disent même d'elle
qu'elle est l'autre face de la pièce
révèle macron d'un côté et marine le pen
de l'autre pour assurer une politique
qui sera toujours celle finalement des
objectifs de l'union européenne avec des
minima sociaux toujours moindre avec
davantage de compétition économique avec
toujours moins de souveraineté pour la
nation française donc oui je ne vois pas
en quoi finalement elle se distingue
beaucoup des modèles macron peut-être un
peu plus de passes et de xénophobie un
peu plus de populisme entre guillemets
mais on a bien du mal dans les
programmes et on attend d'ailleurs les
programmes de madame le pen en matière
économique et autres évidemment
départager ces deux là si ce n'est
qu'ils aimeraient de macron à donner une
image un peu plus moderne un peu plus
progressistes comme il aimait à le dire
sur les sujets sociétaux que ce soit le
tas nazis
soit le mariage pour tous et c'est là où
madame le pen sera plus classique et
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'elle va
essayé de draguer l'électorat de droite
en disant que la seule candidate
crédible à droite c'est elle alors en
tout cas il va plus loin en amont de
bons parce que lui il dit carrément que
c'est la faute à maquereau ans emmanuel
macron qui mettra madame le pen au
pouvoir dit il
il compare d'ailleurs cela aussi au
phénomène trump ou au phénomène du bric
site de naujac et vous qui avez vécu
plusieurs années avec le connaissait
bien les états unis est ce que c'est
réellement comparables à ce phénomène
trump ce qui peut se passer en 2022 et
ce qui va se passer carrément selon
arnaud mambo bon en fait on a toujours
eu que tu me dire qu'on irait vers
marine le pen le jour où on aurait tout
essayé et que les français ont le
sentiment de vraiment tout essayé
jusqu'à la dernière minute d'écart yvan
dans le vide
se disant que tant qu'à sauter autant
sauter avec un nouveau parachute en
attendent puisqu'on considère que les
autres son sang sont plus capable
d'amortir votre chute donc comparable
aux états unis à un ou deux regards oui
le premier c'est comme trump a sua était
un des premiers présidents a parlé à une
amérique qui sentait oublier enfin
parler une amérique qui sont est
déclassé a aussi une population blanche
on a vu qu'ils sentaient a cédé classe
et pas forcément vis-à-vis des noirs
américains s'étaient pas trop le cas
invente une demande et hispaniques mais
surtout il y avait à washington et il ya
le reste de la population et tout à coup
il a su leur parler avec des mots
simples et leur dire je vais vous faire
remonter au créneau vous allez remonter
l'échelle sociale c'était le rêve
américain et je vais vous le rendre je
suis pas sûr que le avec un discours
très business très argent on va créer
des jobs et c'était quand même son sa
promesse principale pour l'instant et
monsieur rappeler à vendre comme on n'a
jamais vraiment bien compris le le
programme économique de marine le pen
qui flirtait quand même plus du côté
gauche que du côté droit là elle s'est
entourée de nouveaux collaborateurs qui
vont peut-être arriver avec des idées un
peu nouvelle plus progressistes etc
mais non c'était quand même avant une
extrême droite avec un programme de
gauche courant
gros donc du coup c'est assez difficile
mais par contre ce qui est clair c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il faut bien comprendre
une chose sexuelle est déjà à 48 % dans
les sondages
un moment donné on n'a pas encore les
vrais effets de la récession qui vont
arriver dans quelques semaines et dans
quelques mois
c'est là on va vraiment savoir si marine
le pen est une chance de gagner sierre
si on rentre vraiment et que les
français sortent de leurs anesthésie
qu'ils réalisent que finalement pour
relativement peu et je le dis en toute
conscience pour relativement peu et
notamment seulement pour quatre ou cinq
mille personnes dans un lit de
réanimation n'a bloqué un pays de 68
millions d'habitants il ya un moment
donné ils vont se poser la question de
savoir pourquoi ils ont perdu leur job
pourquoi ils ont perdu leur entreprise
pourquoi ils ont perdu leur jeunesse
et quand vous voyez aux etats-unis comme
en france que les taux de suicide et les
taux de dépression lourdes franchissent
des bons de 25 ou 28 %
ben il faut pas s'étonner que si les
jeunes montent au créneau demain on sait
selon ipsos et d'autre que au delà de 25
ans ils votent principalement au
rassemblement national donc je pense
qu'elle a vraiment des chances de gagner
oui comme arnaud que je connais bien par
ailleurs et avec quel sens de la formule
beaucoup plus que moi mais c'est vrai
que l a des chances parce que si elle
est déjà 48 dans les intentions
aujourd'hui demain quand la récession va
vraiment montré son vrai visage
elle risque de faire un bond assez
spectaculaire a renommé dévêtissent est
intéressant c'est quelques notions les
oublier la population blanche alors
c'est vrai qu'à une différence notoire à
la même culture au niveau économique
mais ça nous rappelle quelque chose ici
en france la crise des gilets jaunes
effectivement la récession qui peut
arriver
la perte des emplois c'est ça il
pourrait faire gagner marine le pen et
en ce sens c'est emmanuel macron qui en
sort est le responsable
tout simplement parce que si vous voulez
france il ya aujourd'hui des classes
populaires et des classes moyennes qui
ne se retrouvent plus dans les offres
politiques classiques
emmanuel macron avait réussi en 2017 à
incarner une forme de dégagisme mais le
problème c'est que le dégât lyrisme qui
l'incarné n'était finalement qu'une
bouée de sauvetage pour réseau offre
politique qui ne parvenait plus à
performer dans l'électorat
et ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est que
on voit bien que la marque le pen qui
est en train de se recentrer
manifestement elle fait un gros travail
de communication politique et que pour
essayer de polir les aspects qui étaient
les plus allergiques dans son image
marine le pen est en train actuellement
on le voit de modifier son discours
économique e tour finalement essayé de
complaire à une clientèle politique à
droite qui partageaient un certain
nombre de ses convictions sur des sujets
qui étaient les sujets sociétaux
mais qui disons et mettez un certain
nombre de doutes sur son programme
économique
on considère d'ailleurs qu'en 2017 elle
a aussi vraisemblablement connu un échec
en raison de ses propositions
économiques qui pourrait affoler une
partie de cet électorat donc marine le
pen aujourd'hui est en train de créer
des conditions de son éligibilité et
elle n'était pas considérée comme
éligible en 2017
elle est aujourd'hui considérée comme
potentiellement éligibles et les
sondages le démontrent
parce que les sondages qui se réitère
depuis maintenant un certain nombre de
semaines montrent que emmanuel macron
qui avait fait finalement de sa
candidature
le barrage au populisme et perd elle se
retrouve dans une marge d'incertitude au
second tour que les sondages
alain traduisent donc ne serait ce que
la publication ces sondages finissent
par crédibiliser la candidature est là
le potentiel de victoire de marine le
pen
donc ça c'est le premier le premier
essai le deuxième aspect c'est que de
toute façon aujourd'hui il existe une
demande de rupture par rapport à encore
une fois des forces politiques dont on
considère que alternance par alternance
elles ont échoué et marine le pen tout
en se recentrant conserve quand même une
caractéristique majeure de sa marque
c'est le côté qui est certes encore un
peu sulfureux mais qui semble attester
pour une partie de l'opinion qu'elle est
en mesure
d'assurer cette structure donc elle est
une communication politique qui est
assez efficace de ce point de vue et qui
peut la mettre en bonne position
en tout cas pour battre emmanuel macron
en tout cas l'intérêt manifeste de se
retrouver face à emmanuel macron parce
que vraisemblablement peut-être qu
emmanuel macron est le plus mauvais
candidat aujourd'hui pour faire barrage
à marine le pen en l'occurrence est et
ce qui peut se passer quand même parce
qu'on est quand même très loin de
l'élection corps un an c'est énorme et
l'histoire électorale nous démontre que
toutes les projections qui ont été
faites depuis des années des années se
sont trouvés affirmé par les faits si on
suivait les sondages monsieur balladur
était et luxe en 1994 il ne passe pas le
premier tour de l'élection si on suivait
les sondages monsieur jospin avait de
bonnes chances d'être élu il ne passe
pas le premier tour de l'élection si
l'on suivait des sondages
monsieur fillon en novembre 2016 été élu
à la présidence de la république est en
fait ce qu'il en a été
donc il faut être quand même toujours
très prudent mais quand même force est
de constater que aujourd'hui marine le
pen a une capacité à pouvoir agréger
autour d'elle un certain nombre de
mécontentement et de franchir le barrage
et emmanuel macron programme effet un
risque considérable on faisant d'elle un
meilleur opposant justement vous disiez
ils ont intérêt à se retrouver l'un en
face de l'autre ces deux là alors
justement à l'extrême gauche et à l'ego
d'ailleurs ça plaît pas du tout à fait
sorti d'arnaud montebourg les soutiens
de candidats
le candidat mélenchon n'ont pas trop
apprécié regardez ce commentaire du chef
de file de la france a soumis son
département de seine-saint-denis
justement arnaud montebourg a raison sur
emmanuel macron mais totalement tort
d'ignorer que la seule candidature
capable d'être un rempart à le pen et
macron reste jean luc mélenchon
l'ignorer et se rendre complice de la
macro ni ce qui n'est pas normalement
son credo à l'excès pour justement on
avait des ti nous parler de deux
populismes
ce qui fait du populisme emmanuel macron
où il joue justement cette carte de la
division l'exemple même ici à gauche et
il va y avoir un duel entre jean luc
mélenchon et arnaud montebourg
de toute façon la gauche est divisée on
voit bien les tentatives d'avoir une
candidature unique lancée par yannick
jadot d'europe écologie les verts sont
loin d'avoir abouti et ça discute de
tout les côtés mais on est loin d'avoir
et un candidat et un programme commun
jean luc mélenchon lui un programme
il est candidat c'est le seul déclaré et
il compte bien y aller il ya sandrine
rousseau également du côté des dévers
donc il n'y a même pas besoin de diviser
la gauche ni diviser la droite ces deux
grands partis historiques sont de toute
façon divisé et depuis longtemps
la question qui se pose c'est ce qu'est
venu le maquereau a fait du populisme
oui emmanuel macron c'est un trump à la
sauce française
c'est quelqu'un qui était capable de
créer une réalité alternative écouter
ses ministres comme jean michel blanquer
requis sorte mensonge après mensonge
pour se justifier de ratage de leur
administration
ça c'est typiquement train bien le
rapport avec les médias la façon dont
est mené le patron a toujours traité les
médias de manière assez hautaine et
suspicieuse en disant que nous étions
défectueuse que nous étions ceux qui
étaient là pour montrer la face cachée
finalement de ce qu'il veut faire
puisqu'il est entièrement sur la
communication et communicationnel moins
bien sûr que donald trump qui venait de
la télé réalité qui avaient tous les
codes
mais néanmoins on voit bien que c'est me
marchand qui a poussé cette candidature
c'est l'image qui est au coeur
finalement du système macro nist et le
bain et le maquereau nisme c'est un
populisme des élites c'est à peu près la
même recette un chef pas vraiment de
programme et l'idée qu' on a toujours
raison et que les autres ont tort voilà
la réalité aujourd'hui je suis d'accord
avec arnaud benedetti c'est un écart
candidat extrêmement faibles s'il est
question de faire barrage à marine le
pen
c'est sans doute le plus mauvais des
candidats effectivement à mettre en face
de madame le pen en 2022
pour éviter que madame le pen ne puisse
gagner
elle n'a rien à faire elle n'a qu'à
regarder et écouter se taire le plus
longtemps possible avant que de prendre
la parole de voir qui va se rallier à sa
candidature car la question qui va se
poser maintenant c est ce que marine le
pen peut agréger sortir du cadre
classique du rassemblement national et
devenir ce qu'elle rêve c'est-à-dire la
candidate finalement officielle d'une
droite recomposée autour d'elle alors
tout cas on dit souvent que c'est la
colère qui pousserait les français à
voter marine le pen je voudrais qu'on
regarde tout simplement des chiffres
denis jacquet y faisait référence tout à
l'heure ce sont les chiffres du chômage
en france sur fond de pandémie sur un an
6 millions qu'elle 142 1880 français au
chômage en février 2020 un an plus tard
c'est à peu près 442000 de plus c'est
tab so lu ment ça qu'il faut régler ça
va être compliqué d'ici à 2022 on
imagine denis jacquet vous savez pour
reprendre la comparaison avec les états
unis ce qui pouvait faire gagner
joe biden dans cette élection parce que
franchement montreuil mais pas passé si
loin et d'ailleurs je confirme ce que
disait monsieur tout à l'heure sur les
sondages tout le monde l'annoncé
ratiboiser et ça a été très très loin de
ça donc il faut se méfier jusqu'à la
dernière minute mais il ya plusieurs
choses
1 on n'a pas encore les conséquences de
la crise économique qui est qui reste
sous jacente anesthésié sous le tapis
parce que les subventions les prêts les
reports de charges enfin tout dispositif
qui était d'ailleurs indispensable qui a
été mis en place
reste néanmoins une espèce de grosse
masse de poussière sous le tapis un
moment donné le tapis qui va soulever
donc je vous rappelle que c'est quand
même pratiquement huit cent mille
chômeurs de plus en espagne qui a aucune
espèce de chances qu'on fasse mieux en
france donc pour l'instant les
liquidations sont reportés les
redressements judiciaires sont
temporiser et le chômage fruits sous le
l'aspect du chômage partiel donc quand
tout ça va se dévoiler
moi la grande question c'est soit
emmanuel macron a envie de gagner à tout
prix et il va lâcher les vannes ouvrir
le robinet du crédit des aides jusqu'à
l'élection pour s'offrir l'élection avec
de la dette
ça me paraît assez difficile à tenir
encore pendant un an le 5 ou 6 mois il
pourrait tenir mais un an c'est beaucoup
trop loin parce que ses partenaires
européens certains d'entre eux vont ou
un peu sonné la fin de la partie
et la deuxième chose aux etats-unis
c'était plutôt la population noire
américaine qui pouvait décider de
l'élection ce qui s'est passé chez nous
cette fois c'est les jeunes qui
d'habitude votent pas ou peu et là on
sait que alors un peu moins les 18 22
mai au delà de 24 25
si les jeunes sortent cette fois ils
vont ils vont voter massivement au front
national ils peuvent faire
que les choses et en même temps mais il
peut y avoir aussi une surprise
d'ailleurs celle d'un edouard philippe
etc qui lui a peut-être qu encore une
crédibilité pour aller chercher un un
électorat au centre alors qu'aujourd'hui
macron a totalement perdu son aile
gauche de celle qui pourtant l'a aidé à
venir au pouvoir tous ses soutiens
colons et c était quand même plutôt des
gens de gauche à droite bat bien
évidemment il ya enfin des candidats qui
se manifeste donc peut-être avoir des
candidats à droite
et puis il voulait aller mordre sur
l'extrême droite on l'a vu ces derniers
mois avec différents débats qu'il a
lancée mais les gens c'est comme le
canada dry à un moment donné ils
préfèrent l'original que la copie donc
du coup il n'a pas de réserve ni à
droite ni à gauche une situation
économique qui va revenir comme un
tsunami inversée qui va lui retomber
dessus dit scène et prochaine et si les
conséquences sont celles que je pense en
tout cas il ne serait ce que pour les
entreprises on voir le double du taux de
faillite de tous nos voisins européens
on risque d'avoir effectivement un
cataclysme et le qui l'emportera moi je
vois même des scénarios on se retrouve
avec un écolo et marine le pen au second
tour ça ne paraît pas totalement
invraisemblable elle s'apprend mais
effectivement peut-être de grandes
surprises encore merci pour ces analyses
passionnante messieurs arnaud benedetti
denis jacquet et alexis poulain merci à
vous d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur
rt france